un restaurante está anunciando un menú
de tres tiempos que debe incluir plato
fuerte vegetales y bebida aquí tenemos
las opciones vamos a ver qué nos
preguntan cuántos de los menús de tres
tiempos incluyen refresco y el lote
necesitamos que ya incluyan refresco y
elote déjame volver a leer la condición
está anunciando un menú de tres tiempos
que debe incluir platos fuertes
vegetales y bebida hay que escoger un
platillo aquí un platillo acá y la
bebida pero nos están diciendo que ya
tenemos el refresco
y que ya tenemos el elote es decir ya
elegimos de esta categoría y de esta
categoría de acá así que ahora lo que
bastaría o lo que faltaría es encontrar
es encontrar cuántas posibilidades
tenemos de plato fuerte no nada más que
serían dos pollo y res entonces la
respuesta debe ser dos dos a dos
posibilidades déjame volver a explicarlo
es más vamos a enlistar las
posibilidades así explícitamente una de
ellas es elegir el menú que tiene pollo
elote y refresco y la otra es elegir el
menú que tiene res
res elote y refresco vaya usualmente
tenemos que elegir las tres cosas del
plato fuerte los vegetales y la bebida
pero aquí ya nos dan la elección de
dólar de dos de las categorías la fuerza
tenemos que elegir refresco y elote y
entonces la forma en la cual podemos
pensar esto es simplemente en lo que
tenemos que elegir en el plato fuerte y
entonces queda que son dos posibilidades
vale la respuesta es
vamos ahora al problema 16 en el
problema 16 dice que diego le puso
precio a seis reproductores de mp3 y los
precios fueron los siguientes
210 230 210 390 250 y 310 y lo que nos
preguntan es cuál es la mediana
cuál es la mediana de estos precios
bueno pues entonces el truco de este
problema simplemente pues es acordarnos
qué quiere decir la mediana de un
conjunto de información y simplemente la
mediana es lo que está a la mitad así
literalmente tenemos que ordenar estos
números que ahorita lo voy a hacer y ver
que el número queda a la mitad entonces
los voy a poner
empezando por 210 que es el más pequeño
210 tenemos por acá otros 210 210 luego
tenemos un 230
luego un 250
250 por aquí un 310
310 y finalmente trescientos noventa
entonces ya están en orden y ahora lo
que tenemos que hacer es ver cuál de
estos números está en medio pero aquí
tenemos un problema porque como es una
cantidad par de números no hay un solo
número que quede a la mitad aquí tenemos
dos números a la mitad que serían el 230
y el 250 y no podemos decir que ninguno
de ellos esté exactamente a la mitad por
ejemplo el 230 tiene dos arriba y tres
abajo y el 250 tiene tres arriba y dos
abajo cuando tenemos una cantidad par de
números lo que tenemos que hacer es
considerar estos dos pero al final de
cuentas la mediana debe ser sólo un
número entonces lo que se hace es
literalmente sacarles el promedio a
estos dos encontrar el número que queda
justo a la mitad aquí se puede ver a
simple vista que es 240
240 pero puede ser que no seamos tan
suertudos y ya lo mejor no es tan fácil
ver cuál número está a la mitad y lo que
tenemos que hacer es sacar sacar la
media aritmética o el promedio
simplemente los sumamos
230 más 250 y luego dividimos entre 2 y
esto debe dar 240 vamos a ver esto de
aquí es igual a 480
480 dividido entre 2 y eso en efecto es
240 otra vez aquí era muy fácil darse
cuenta que 240 quedaba justo a la mitad
pero pero este es el procedimiento en
general por si estos fueran números más
feos como números grandes o fracciones
vale bueno entonces sería sería 240 y la
respuesta es b